Chris Morgan has way too much time on
his hands obviously Susan Sarandon
speaks out on her Twitter few with Piers
Morgan it all started last week when the
TV personality tweeted about the
actresses ensemble at the SAG Awards
calling it horribly inappropriate which
compelled thousands of fans to clap back
in Sarandon stew fence I love the
Solidarity of women that came forward
with that I was Morgan has way too much
time on his hands obviously be that
upset but I was very happy that all the
girls came forward you must have got a
lot of positive feedback a lot of pauses
I know they got a lot of positive but I
think they all sent him lots of pictures
of their breasts so he must be happy to
write speaking of fashion Sarandon 23
year old son miles joined her on the
zoolander 2 red carpet is fashion is a
very complicated are most people don't
understand the belly this is a piece
called po namin my tongue club haircut
john kerr makes me want to pet it makes
me like you do sitters there's an aspect
it that's inviting but don't get it
dirty not our hands okay no what's
happening here on this is a Garlington
is it comfortable no suffering for
fashion is part of the idea I screeches
comfortable or not
alone